Çeviri: Gözde Caymazer
Gözden geçirme: Erman Turkmen
Gönenç Gürkaynak
Avukat
Ben size bugün iki Mehmet etrafında
dönen bir hikaye anlatacağım.
Bu hikayede baş aktörlerden bir tanesi
benim üç yaşındaki oğlum.
Daha üç yaşında olmadı aslında,
Ocak sonunda üç yaşında olacak.
Mehmet, benim şanslı olduğum akşamlarda
benim tarafımdan uykuya götürülür.
Mehmet’e ben anlatmaya çalışırım
ne iş yaptığımı, her seferinde sorar
bir türlü daha o konuda mutabık kalamadık.
"Sen ne iş yapıyorsun?" diye sorar.
Ben de "avukatım ben,
hakları korurum" derim.
Hak hukuk tabi bunlar beş yaşında
öğrenmesini düşündüğüm kavramlar.
Dolayısıyla şu an itibariyle Mehmet döner
tekrar sorar "Neyi koruyorsun ama?" der.
Bakarım ümit yok, dönerim Mehmet’e derim
ki "Oğlum ben aslında yenilikçi düşünceyi
koruduğumu düşünüyorum, ifade hürriyetini
koruyorum yavrum ben.
Ben aslında yolsuzlukla mücadele
alanında çalışmalar yapıyorum,
dolayısıyla rekabetçi piyasa dengelerini
koruduğumu düşünüyorum çocuğum." derim.
O da bana ve tabi diğer alanlarımı böyle
bir hırs sayarım. Rekabet hukuku vesaire.
Çocuk daha gözünü belertmeyi öğrenmediği
bir yaşta olduğu için gözünü
belertemeyerek bari kelimesini de
bilmediğinden bana bir hikaye anlat der.
Yani adam uçmuş bari bir hikaye anlatsın.
Bunun üzerine ona hikaye anlatmak için
sorarım sana neli bir hikaye anlatayım?
Bizim aramızdaki bir ritüeldir bu.
İçinde ne olsun? Greyder olsun, zürafa
olsun, Boris olsun
- Boris bizim kurt köpeğimiz-
bir de stadyum olsun.
Mutlaka stadyumla bitirmesi
gerektiğini de bilir.
Çünkü hikayelerin sonunda stadyuma
gideriz, stadyumda ben
"oo Beşiktaşım oley, Beşiktaşım
oley, Beşiktaşım oley" derim.
Çocuğu hazin Beşiktaşlılık öyküsüne
hazırlamaya çalışırken ve
o da bu ritüelle uykuya dalar.
Bu hep böyle olur.
Şimdi bugün sizlere de bir
hikaye anlatacağım.
Bu hikayenin içerisinde de domates olacak,
Bülent Eczacıbaşı olacak,
kelle paça olacak, gergedan yavrusu
olacak, keman olacak,
tekerlekli sandalye olacak, basketbol
olacak, insan olacak, kucaklaşma olacak.
Bu kim diye sorarsam Akşemsettin
Hazretleri, karşısındaki de
Fatih Sultan Mehmet Han.
Ders öğrenmeye çalışıyor.
Yedi dil bilen, o dönemin ciddi bilgi ile
donanmış insanlarından biri
Fatih Sultan Mehmet.
Şöyle bakarsak bize daha tanıdık hali.
Fatih Sultan Mehmet mi daha iyi bir refah
seviyesinde daha iyi bir hayat yaşadı,
yoksa bizler mi daha iyi bir refah
seviyesinde daha iyi bir hayat yaşıyoruz
sorusunun etrafında döneceğiz bugün.
Fatih Sultan Mehmet'in hayatı mı daha
iyiydi bizim ki mi daha iyiydide
birisinden yardım alacağız.
Bu kim?
Tanıştınız artık Mehmet, benim oğlum.
Ben dalış yapmayı çok seven bir insanım.
Bazen iyi dalış tatili denk gelirse o
zaman tropik bir yerlere gitme
imkanım oluyor. Mehmet bunlardan
bir tanesinde haspam
bir yandan köpüklerin içerisinde
çiçekler falan koymuşlar.
Tabi eve dönüldüğü zaman "çiçek yok
mu" dediği zaman git lan diyoruz
kendisine ama yani orada öyle
bir hayat yaşıyor şu anda.
Bu havuzdan çıktığı zaman
şu meyvelerden yiyecek.
Bu meyveleri ben ilk defa orada tattım,
bir kısmını.
Daha böyle gönlüme yakın olan armut yok
mu filan gibi sorular sorduktan sonra
bir kısmını bunların yedim,
fakat meyve Mehmet için böyle bir şey.
Meyve bu. Tabi iPhone’dan, vesaireden
de bakabildiği için mütemadiyen
tatil resimlerine, bu hep de taze kalıyor
ve perçinleniyor, dolayısıyla
meyve nedir yavrum diye sorduğunuz
zaman arasında böyle passion fruit
gibi laflar geçen bir şeyler
söyleniyor yani.
Bu tabi Mehmet ile bir diğer Mehmet
arasındaki bir refah farkına da
işaret etmeye başlıyor.
Bu ne?
Domates.
Hikayede de geçeceğini söylemiştik.
Kavramların hepsi geçecek.
Domatesi bilmeyen birisi var,
o da Fatih Sultan Mehmet.
Hayatında domates görmedi. Yedi dil
konuşurdu ama domatesle
hiçbir zaman hiçbir işi olmadı.
Fatih Sultan Mehmet, kırk dokuz
yaşında vefat etti.
Kırk dokuz yaşında vefat ettiğinde
erken gitti diyen olmadı.
Allah uzun ömürler verirse inşallah benim
Mehmet’im, ikinci Murat'ın Mehmet'inden
bir 30-40 yıl daha uzun yaşayacaktır.
Zira Türkiye'de şansa yaşadığımız halde
ortalama ömür 78 yıl şu anda.
Tabi neden öldü diye bakacak olursanız
Fatih Sultan Mehmet
bu da refah farkına işaret edebilir.
Gut hastalığından öldü.
O zaman tabir ettikleri şekliyle
nikristen öldü Fatih Sultan Mehmet.
Gut hastalığından bir yandan ölüyordu ama
bir yandan da gıda maddeleri arasında,
en sevdiği yiyecekleri arasında
kelle, paça, pilav yiyor bizim gibi ama
sizin bildiğiniz pilavdan değil.
Sıkı durun şimdi.
Vakfı kebir yağıyla amberbu pirincinden
yapılmış beyinli bıldırcınlı pilav yiyor.
Beyin kolesterol haritasının neresinde
kalır bir fikriniz var mı?
Gayet iyi bir fikriniz var ve hekim
olmayanların da gayet iyi bir fikri var.
Oysa onun başhekimi
Yakup Paşa'nın hiçbir fikri yoktu.
Yakup Paşa'nın hiçbir fikri yoktu
derken Yakup Paşa'ya ayıp etmeyelim.
Gerçekten samimi söylüyorum
ayıp edebiliriz bir insanın hatırasına.
Yakup Paşa o dönemin en
yavan hekimlerinden biriydi.
Yakup Paşa, otuz yıl saray
başhekimliği yapmış bir insandı.
Otuz yıl saray başhekimliği
yapmak için nasıl bir kredibilite
lazım fikriniz var mı?
Defalarca padişaha gidip padişahın yakını
için derman yoktur devletlum diyeceksiniz.
O da Yakup Paşa böyle
diyorsa böyledir diyecek otuz yıl.
Otuz yıl bunu yapabilmiş bir insan
ama semptomatik tedaviye giriyor.
Kayıtlara bakın. Padişahımızın mübarek
ayaklarına kara kara sular indi,
o suları çektik diyor.
Suyla mücadelede.
Çünkü kolesterol nedir bir fikri yok,
besledikleri şeyden bunun olduğuna dair
bir fikri yok, babası da bundan öldü,
ondan öncekiler de bundan öldü,
padişahlarımıza bir hastalık musallat
oluyor ama hadi hayırlısı durumundalar.
Bu esnada da siz olsanız şurada
bir hızlı el cihazından
bir arama yapın desem "abi C vitamini
lazımmış ya" dersiniz bana.
Yakup Paşa, "C vitamini ne lan" durumunda.
Çünkü vitaminin ne olduğunun
anlaşılmasına 500 yıl var.
Oysa doğada vitamin var.
Yani bir şeyin keşfedilmiş olması
gerekiyor, anlaşılmış olması gerekiyor
C vitaminine yürünebilmesi için.
İşte Yakup Paşanın dramı ve Fatih Sultan
Mehmet Han çağ açıp çağ kapayan,
İstanbul'u fethetmek suretiyle
orta çağı kapatıp yeni çağı başlatan
en kudretli hükümdarın gidebileceği yolun
en uzun boyu o dönem için.
Peki bu refah farkına yol açan şey ne?
O refah farkına yol açan şey her ne ise
şu insanı da haksız çıkaran şey.
Bu insan Thomas Maltus.
İngiltere’nin ilk iktisat profesörü.
Maltus’un teoremine göre ki kimse
bugün de dönüp deli saçmasıymış
yahu bu demiyor, teori doğru.
Ama bir şey oluyor arada.
Maltus diyor ki gıda maddeleri
aritmatik dizi şeklinde artıyorlar.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10 diziminde.
Halbuki nüfus, geometrik dizi
olarak artıyor.
2’yi birim değer kabul
edecek olursak,
2, 4, 8, 16, 32, 64, 128, 256,
nüfus böyle artıyor.
İşte bu imtizaçsızlıktan, bu
uyumsuzluktan dolayı diyor Maltus
1789 senesinde, kıran geçiren
bir takım kıtlıklar yaşanacak,
insan soyları belli kıtalarda
tükenecekler, yiyecek maddeleri için
yoğun savaşlar yaşanacak ve gıda
en önemli problem halini alacak.
Böyle bir şey yoktur demiyorum.
Açlık bugün için de çok ciddi
bir sorundur dünyada.
Ama 1789’dan beri de anlatılan
şekilde bir şey olmadı.
Bunun olmamasının sebebiyle ikinci
Murat’ın Mehmet’iyle, benim Mehmet’im
arasındaki refah farkını
yaratan şey aynı şey.
Tabi Fatih Sultan Mehmet’in refah
fonksiyonuna harem kısmını
koymamanızı rica ederim. Benim oğlumun
bununla boy ölçüşebileceğini zannetmem.
(Gülüşmeler)
Fakat eğer normal insan refah fonksiyonuna
bakacak olursak bu ikisi arasındaki
yoğun farkı yaratan, Maltus'u da haksız
çıkaran insanların birbirleriyle
kucaklaşık şekilde, özgür bir biçimde,
birbirlerinin düşüncesi üstüne
düşünce inşaa ederek, yenilikçi
düşünceye doğru yürüyerek
teknolojiyi besleyebilmeleri ve bu
suretle de en önemli refah motoru olan
dinamik etkinliği, teknolojiyi ortaya
çıkarabilmiş olmalarıdır.
Bizi insanlar olarak aslında refaha
götürmekte olan
en önemli unsurlardan bir tanesi budur.
Bunu gözleyeceğimiz zaman tabi insan
beyninden bir analoji kullanabiliriz.
İnsanın kendi beyni ve bir toplumun
beyni mukayesesine girebiliriz.
Bu beyin insan beyni, Fatih Sultan
Mehmet'in yediği beyinden değil.
Bu insan beyni, aslında bizim her şeyimiz.
Varsınlar bize beyin-kalp dengesi
anlatadursunlar aslında her şeyin
olup bittiği yer beyin.
Kalpte olduğunu zannettiğimiz şeyin
olup bittiği yer de beyin.
Burada da şu anda beyinler var.
Ben bir şey söylüyorum, bir şey
söylediğim zaman siz gülüyorsunuz,
siz güldüğünüzde bende bir ışıklar
yanıyor, gergin değilsem rahatlıyorum,
benim beynimde birtakım
transformasyonlar olurken
ay beni sevdiler galiba heyecanına ben
girerken bir yandan sizler de
söylediklerimden esinleniyorsunuz,
düşünüyorsunuz,
bir kısmınız efendim bu
düşünceleri yayacaksınız.
Mütemadiyen beyinlerimiz
enteraksiyon halinde.
Bu toplantının yapılması için
hür olduğumuz ortamda.
Burada, bu beynin içinde de olup biten
bir şey var aslında o da ruh.
Ruhumuz da benim düşünce ve kanaatime
göre yine beynimizin içinde olup bitiyor.
Hiç ruh gördünüz mü?
Ben size ruh fotoğrafı
göstereceğim şimdi.
Ruh bu. Nöron.
Nöronlar, bizim sabahleyin kalktığımızda
aynı insan olarak kalkmamızı,
hatıralarımızı muhafaza etmemizi,
hatıralarımızdan kalkınarak
tecrübe edinmemizi, kendimizi
şekillendirmemizi,
ortama kendimizi adapte etmemizi,
her şeyimizi ama her şeyimizi sağlıyor.
Öldüğümüzde ruhun bedenden
çıkması benim kanaatime göre
nöronlarımızın da bu hatıralarımızla
beraber sönmesi şeklinde oluyor.
Nöronlarımızı kaybediyoruz ve
ruhumuzu da böylelikle kaybediyoruz.
Kalbe de, geri kalan her şeye de
hükmeden nöron.
Beynin yapısalları yerli yerinde değilse
bu enteraksiyonda problem yaşayabiliriz.
Ki bu bir toplum
için özgürlüğün ta kendisidir.
Özgürlük yoksa zaten o
irtibatlılıkta bir problem yaşayabiliriz
ve bir şeyleri beraber inşa etmekte
toplumca beraber inşa etmekte
problem yaşayabiliriz. Ama özgürlük
kendi başına yetmiyor.
Özgürlüğün yanı sıra ruh olması lazım.
Beyni tamam bir insan yetmiyor.
O insanın nöronlarının, bir trilyona
yakın nöronunun mütemadiyen
telaş halinde bir şeyler
üretiyor olması lazım.
Birbiriyle etkileşiyor olması lazım.
Toplumda da bireylerin birbirleriyle
etkileşiyor olması, bireylerin aynı
şekilde birbirleriyle
bir araya geliyor olması ve kolektif
bir çabaya girilebiliyor olması lazım.
Özgürlüğün yanı sıra toplumun ihtiyaç
duyduğu şey ruh ve o ruh insan sevgisi,
canlıların sevgisi, insanların vicdanı,
birbirini kollayıp birbiriyle
bir yerlere gitme hevesi olarak
kendini gösteriyor.
Bu, Urfa da yaptırdığımız bir okul. Ben
Urfalı değilim. Çanakkale Bigalıyım ben.
Ama bir yerde okul yaptırmak istiyorum
çünkü gerçekten de Türkiye'de
her şeyin başı eğitim ve her şeyin başı
eğitimi tebessümle dahi söyleyemiyorum
çünkü her şeyin başı eğitim
durumunda bir insanım.
Dolayısıyla nereye okul yaptırılması
gerektiği sorulduğunda da Urfa Türkiye'nin
en fazla okula ihtiyaç duyulan yeri olduğu
için kendi büromla beraber
bir okul yaptırma işine girdim.
Bu Urfa'daki okul, devletin de
himasiyle daha sonra büyüdü.
Devletin de katkılarıyla bir
orta okula dönüştü
ve dört dörtlük bir eğitim verilen yere
dönüşme yolunda gidiyor inşallah.
Bunu yaptığım zaman
Yaşar Kemal beni çağırdı.
Duymuş ve omzuma dokunup dedi ki
"Türkiye'de eğitim ve sanat
en önemli iki konudur.
Aferin sana çocuk."
Ben “aa sanat dedi” oldum.
Bunun üzerine çok ünlü kemancı
Anne Sophie Mutter Türkiye'ye gelirken
İKSV'ye sponsor olduk ve İKSV'de
Yaşar Kemal’i de çağırdık,
sanat demiştiniz dedik.
Geldi, kırmadı.
Arada ben yanına gittiğimde dedi ki
Yaşar Kemal "Sen önde oturmalısın."
"Bülent Eczacıbaşı’nın yanında oturmalısın."
Efendim ben böyle iyiyim dedim. Hayır
sponsor olarak orada oturmalısın dedi.
Zaten İKSV de bunu böyle istedi. Gittim
Bülent Eczacıbaşı'nın yanına oturdum.
Dikkat ederseniz noktaları
birleştirmek konusunu anlatıyorum.
Kendim öngöremeyeceğim bir
hikayenin nasıl kendi kendine
örüldüğünü arz etmeye çalışıyorum. Burada
Bülent beyle sohbet ettik, hasbihâl ettik.
Bülent Bey dedi ki sizin gibi bir avukata
TÜSİAD'da da ihtiyaç olur.
"Lütfen TÜSİAD'a da gider misiniz?"
Benim o zaman da yakın ahbabım
ve müvekkilim olan Ümit Boyner
başkanlığını yapmaktaydı TÜSİAD'ın.
Hay hay dedim yine ve bu sefer TÜSİAD'a
girdim. Bu bir tarafta kalsın.
Birazdan yeri gelecek.
Bu noktalar böyle birleşmeye başlasınlar
noktaları birleştirmek öyküsünde.
Bir taraftan da ben artık Yaşar Kemal'den
de aldığım ilhamla ve genel olarak da
gördüğüm "yahu benim büyük
idealler peşinde koşmam yetmiyor,
aynı zamanda insan insana birbirimizin
hayatına somut olarak
dokunuyor olmamız lazım. Elden gelen bir
şey varsa bunu küçük kendi haddimiz olan
dokunma çevrelerimizde de yapıyor
olmamız lazım. Topluma ruh veren bu.
Nöronları harekete geçiren, sevgiden bir
şeyler yaratan bu." dediğim noktaya
gitmiştim ki ben öyle sevgi böceği
bir insan değilim.
Hatta etrafımda soracak olursanız benden
çekinen insan epey vardır.
İş hayatında oldukça sert olduğum
vs gibi iddaiar da vardır.
Ama sonuç itibariyle ben artık insanın
insana dokunması gerektiğinde çok rahattım
Tekerlekli iskemle basketboluna
yatırım yapmaya karar verdim.
Engelli yıldızlar kulübü. Türkiye'nin
en köklü kulübüne sponsor olduk.
Sponsor olduğumuz noktada en
büyük hevesim, engellileri alıp
toplum hayatına kazandırmakta
bu sporun etken olacağıydı.
O esnada Melda Hanım –Tüsiad'ın genel
sekreter yardımcısıdır- döndü dedi ki
Renkli Kampüs diye bir şey var.
Renkli Kampüs'e gidip şöyle bir
30-40 kişilik öğrenci grubuna bir
konuşma yapmak ister misiniz?
Hay hay olur dedim.
Bir hafta sonu gittim Renkli Kampüs'te
konuşma yaptım öğrenci grubuna.
O konuşma çok beğenilmiş,
duyulmuş vesaire.
TEDx bana konuşma yapmamı teklif etti.
Şimdi sizlere bu konuşmayı yapıyorum.
Bir sürü noktalar var burada.
Hayatımda hiçbir arada görmediğim
sayıda nokta var.
Onlara tekerlekli sandalye
basketbolundan bahsediyorum
ve onlara takımlara sponsor
olunabildiğinden bahsediyorum.
Bunun videosu dönecek ve noktalar hala
bir şekilde bir fonksiyon ifa ediyorlar
ve iyi bir şeyler oluyor.
Benim kontrolüm dışındaki iyi bir şeyler
oluyor. Ben bu resmi göremiyorum.
Hiçbirimizin göremediği gibi.
Ama bu iyi şeyler gerçek insanların
gerçek hayatlarına dokunuyor.
Asiye ve Selin.
İki tane bayan basketbolcu
tekerlekli sandalyede.
Bayan basketbolunda iki insan.
Bunlar bizim takımımızdalar.
Bu iki insan ve diğer takımın tamamıyla
geçtiğimiz Salı günü
Fatih Çapa'daki kulüpte yemek yedik.
O yemekte sohbetler ettik ve
görüyorum ki Asiye ve Selin,
başka kızları bu spora çekebilirler.
Zaten ben kızım, dışarıda ne işim var
düşüncesinde olabilecek olan bir de
üstüne engelliyim, ben evde oturayım
diyecek insanları spora kavuşturabilirler.
İşte biz bu yapı içerisinde
artık yürümek durumundayız
ve birbirimize bu sevgi bağıyla da
bağlanmak durumundayız.
Bunu en iyi anladığım örneği de
Twitter üzerinde yaşadım.
Benim mütevazi bir Twitter hesabım var.
Yedi bin takipçisi olan bir hesap.
Yedi bin takipçi olmasının önemi şu;
şu resmi gönderip de hikayesini
açıkladığım zaman altı yüzü
aşkın retweet aldı.
Benim gibi bir insan için "ne oluyoruz
ya!" deme sebebidir bu.
Barack Obama gönderdiğinde normal
olabilir bu retweet rakamı.
Ama benim açımdan muazzam bir rakamdır.
Peki "ne oluyoruz ya"nın cevabı neydi?
Bu yavru gergedanın annesini
avcılar öldürmüş.
Yavru gergedanın annesini avcılar
öldürdükten sonra bu yavru gergedan
bir safari esnasında yanaşan Jeep'i
annesi zannetmiş.
Onun o dev gri gövdesine gitmiş siftiniyor
yaklaşıyor. Annesini bulduğunu zannediyor.
Bunu açıklayarak bir tweet gönderdiğimde
kıyamet yerine döndü ortalık.
Bana da şunu öğretti;
özgürlüğümüz tabi önemli.
Örneğin Twitter'ın açık olması
bir özgürlük unsuru.
Ama bununla beraber aslında bizleri
enteraksiyona sokan, bizleri düşünceye
sevk eden, harekete geçiren şey
sevgi bağının ta kendisi.
Bir ortak sevgi bağı, bir duygu.
Nöronların birbiriyle çarpışması,
nöronların birbirinden etkilenmesi ve
yaratıcı düşüncenin ortaya çıkması gibi
insanların düşünce inşa edebilmeleri
ve insan soyunu daha ileri götürebilmeleri
için de zorunlu faktörlerden
biri ruh, insan sevgisi, canlı sevgisi.
Ve eğer bu olmuyor, saygı duruşlarında
insanlar yuhalanıyorsa
o zaman tedirgin olmak vakti. O zaman
bize neler oluyor sorusunu
derhal sormak vakti. Çünkü mücadelenin
sadece özgürlük mücadelesi olmadığını
anlamaya başladığınız
noktadasınız demektir.
Düşmanımız nedir derseniz,
düşmanımız gözünü belertmek,
bıkkınlık, sıkılmak, kendini yargılayıcı
bir şekilde başkalarının üzerinde görmek
ve genel olarak bunlar-biz
noktasında kalmaktır.
Kim olursanız olun, "ben çok modernim
onlar değil" de bunun içerisindedir,
"ben çok gelenekselim, dini bütünüm
onlar değil" de bunun içerisinde olabilir.
Her tür göz belertme, her tür nöronların
birbiriyle kucaklaşmasını yani
toplumdaki bireylerin birbiriyle
kucaklaşmasını sakatlayan,
buna ket vuran her tür duygu,
her tür göz belertme.
Bundan ayrı kaldığımız bir ömür boyunca
faydalı oluruz diye düşünüyorum.
Sizlere sabrınız için çok
teşekkür ediyorum.
(Alkışlar)